today's topic victim blaming in our
video where we talked about flight
reaction
whatever responsibilities he may have
had and his a relationship that seemed
fairly toxic it was a whole long threat
it was a you know long discussion i
thought there was some interesting
points if you guys want to know more you
can go watch our video on this topic
but i know sometimes our delivery is
very dry yeah it seems like it's lagging
compassion it's like
it's like eating salt and vinegar chips
but nobody ever gave you a glass of
water
after a while you're like oh my god i
can't handle this i feel like the term
victim blaming is so broadly used
that it almost absolves people of any
responsibility towards their own
safety look if you're in the street and
you get robbed that's a terrible thing
and the person who did that to you is
guilty
they made that choice what they did to
you was wrong
i think we all agree on that notion we
agree that being said
maybe it's just where i come from
anywhere i've ever lived
any place i've ever been to any
situation i may have fallen like
my parents the people always taught me
like take what precautions you can
towards your personal safety and your
well-being so
when you're walking through a shoddy
neighborhood don't walk around with your
chained out
and your money hanging out your pockets
because will get thirsty
that's not a video like the beginning of
the week it was someone
going through the hood with a ps5
box and he's crossing the street because
he sees
a gang of people a group of people he
crossing the street
to not go in front of them with the and
what happened the people saw that he had
a ps5
they crossed his cheat with him and what
do you think happened whatever happened
happened
yes snatching a ps5
from someone is bad it is
but you're walking in the hood with ps5
no bags nothing
nothing to me these kinds of concepts of
looking out for
dangerous red flags like tell people
like yo you should look out for that you
should understand like
that shouldn't have been something you
go down to to me is not victim it's me
telling you
what mistakes not to make so you don't
end up in that situation again
we can't rid ourselves of evil people we
can't rid ourselves of people who are
willing to do you wrong
what we should do is arm ourselves with
some level of responsibility so that we
can take care of our own well-being
you know it's kind of like those uh
stories of white girls who go down to
like rural mexico
not knowing any spanish and go
hitchhiking and disappear forever
do i feel bad yes did the cartel do
something terrible to them
of course but what were you thinking
to me to think that way is a very
privileged way of thinking
it's it's this way of thinking that you
live in a bubble where you're just like
i'm going to walk through life just
doing whatever i want if something
happens to me it's their fault
no you have some responsibility it
doesn't change the fact that you deserve
sympathy
doesn't change the fact that you were
the one who was wronged
but you have a responsibility towards
your personal safety
and that will never change blame and
responsibility are a different thing
blame just means that
you are somehow culpable for this and
therefore that's it
responsibility is talking about what you
owe to yourself
can you say that again
need to hear that
blame and responsibility
ain't the same no they're not even in
the same boat
right they're not even in the same race
oh
you owe it to yourself oh wow at the end
i want you guys to be safe
it's not about blaming you it's not
about me trying to make you feel bad i
know
sometimes when you go through something
negative you can't just try to blame
yourself
it's not what i'm trying to encourage i
just want
i want y'all to be safer that's it i
just want y'all to protect yourselves
better
and i want you guys to value yourself if
flight valued himself you would not have
been in that situation
you cannot truly truly respect yourself
to the utmost degree
and allow yourself to be with somebody
that you think is toxic
you just can't you can't and so
i don't want you guys to deal with that
and i don't want anyone else to so
if you see red flags listen look out
understand that they mean something
someone doesn't agree to stuff like
faking pregnancies or putting their
hands on you and start being you
understand that means something
significant don't let them try to rope
you back
in i understand it's difficult i'm not
saying it's not complicated
but you owe it to yourself to respect
yourself
to be responsible listen life comes with
a sense of
power but it also comes with a sense of
responsibilities
you don't get to walk through this world
and say i have all these rights and all
this stuff
well that means you have
responsibilities that's just the way it
works
i'm an adult i got money great i got
responsibilities i got taxes to pay
bills to pay
people to take care of comes with the
territory i can't abdicate that no
matter how much
know how much i try and i also
understand that not every situation is
the same when it comes to these kinds of
relationships sometimes a child just hit
a lot of hosting sometimes you're being
beaten
and it's a completely different ballgame
definitely but we were responding to
that situation specifically
now you guys say well you know all the
situations you guys they're not
comparable
flight himself says i saw a bunch of red
flags
but i chose to ignore him the crazy
thing is
that i've seen certain red flags like
this before she was even pregnant but i
would ignore them you know what i'm
saying it's just my stubbornness
sometimes you are
cognizant of this person to me that's
like when you're driving on a road
and there's a sign that says hey man
it's dangerous up ahead
there may be wolves and then you keep
driving there's another sign that says
hey man wolves just ate somebody here an
hour ago
then you keep driving and there's
another sign that says there's wolves
here right here right now
if you keep driving at some point you
have to understand you saw the signs but
you decided to not
be ace of base ah sort of sign you know
i mean like
what can i do and it opened up my eyes
you just kept on driving
you know i mean we're not going to get
rid of wolves we put the sides there to
try to keep you safe
so that was my issue with flight to one
two people made him sound like a
powerless person what confused me about
this whole thing is that she wanted a
relationship with him
right right this person he couldn't say
no to her
but apparently when it came to being
committed in relationship he was able to
i don't want to i want to keep it casual
i want to see other women i never like
try to lead her on like i wanted her to
be my driver always told her like i'm
not ready for relationship
and she understood it it got cool so to
me i'm confused
how can you be a powerless person with
no agency but you have enough agency to
not give
the person who's meeting you the thing
that they want the most
to me what it just strikes me as is
flight has no pin or discipline
this girl has literally lied to me about
being pregnant two
times a girl says she fakes a pregnancy
and you keep busting in her
eyes and you keep busting in a raw like
how are you still the victim in all this
thrice am i confused
i i don't i am what do we preach on this
channel
yo being accountable for yourself so so
so in in what situation
is it good for us to not make him
realize that he's making decisions
cognizant like aware that are very bad
for him
on bad impulses you guys think you're
doing a service by be like oh my god no
you're the big
no what you're doing is you're enabling
his bad habits to make him refund those
situations again
could a person wrote the thread or
anything anybody that that
thought that way i understand why you
would say that but then if we are
victim blaming and we don't take
accountability for what why do you lock
your doors
why do you lock your doors because the
person that's robbing you is just bad
you shouldn't rob you
you shouldn't lock your dog locking your
doors would actually incinerate that
you're doing something bad
if i'm a father and i have a daughter
yes i wish i could tell my daughter
you should be able to walk anywhere
you want and no one should harm you you
can walk in the street naked
and nothing should happen to you they
don't have the right to do anything to
you
i could say that but to me i don't know
maybe i'm victim blaming here but to me
my job as a parent is my daughter to
come back home
safe and i'm gonna take all the
precautions that i can take and give all
the tools
for my daughter to come back home
unarmed so i'm not gonna tell her
fill her with utopia ideas of safe space
and things that should happen that will
not happen
because we live in the real world that
being said
when something happens to you once
shame on them but if it happens to you a
lot of time
i'm not saying that all the blame is on
that person that all the blame that
all the people that are living in the
abusive relationship i'm not saying that
all the blame is on you
you shouldn't be in an abusive
relationship and that person is a trash
person
that being said if you stay there and
you don't put your foot down
and you don't say what it is like it is
you have a part of responsibility
that's to me so
to me i get that people want to try to
be compassionate but there is a point
where compassion
uh makes people so soft that they just
become
sheep ready to be devoured by wolves and
i don't think that's how we want to grow
people doormats
we can approach people with compassion
while also trying to teach them
importance
become a doormat that everybody wiped
their feet on
and days before they step inside you
never get to go in the house
but everybody that's going to go in the
house going to wipe their feet on you
what three times
three times one times two times
that's why clef right there three times
really hey man lied about being break
like a i'm not saying carry a bazooka in
case someone tries to pull a knife on
you
what i'm saying is understand what a
dangerous neighborhood looks like
understand what it means when you walk
into a club and there's an atmosphere of
like oh it might pop off here
understand what it means when you're
with a woman and she's showing you
potential signs that
oh i may be controlling and i may be
trying to trap you understand what it
means when you're with a dude
who may be just trying to use you for
whatever gains that he wants
if you're not willing to take those
precautions
to protect yourself then you will always
be a victim
there's no amount of stuff that me
preached or anybody else in the world
can do to stop people like that from
existing
but what you can do for yourself that
will protect you
is to arm yourself with a bit of
self-awareness a little bit of
perception
right to be able to read danger before
it ever comes right
because the best defense is prevention
isn't that true right like people don't
recommend like listen even when you're
in the bedroom they don't say
hey man buy plenty of playing beasts
amen uh get ready at your abortion
clinic now what do they say is what
where a cup right prevention is the best
for
line of defense and so i just want
people to be safe even me that's all i
can it's a survival thing
i don't know how you were raised i don't
know how you were raised i don't know
how a lot of other people raise but
where i'm come from if you don't arm
yourself with responsibility for your
own personal safety
if you run into situations that could
have easily been prevented
had you had just a tad bit of foresight
then people feels less sympathy for you
and it's not surprising
these are things that you need to do for
your own survival they're too busy
surviving themselves
could you imagine if i ran off into the
jungle and got my leg bit off by a lion
people be like oh my god they were like
what are you doing
it's like no it's like that dude that
went in an island
off of india that people told him not to
go there
because and he wanted to convert them
and he got greeted by arrows
now he did can i feel bad
can we after the warning the red flags
the no don't do it you decided to go
listen the last thing i want to say is
this it's a message to my mom
mama mama thank you
because uh you remember when i was a kid
and i was running and you told me not to
run
and i was running and i pumped my head
and you didn't come running and hugging
you was like
there you bumped your head and i told
you what what i tell you and then you
send me to my room
thank you that was accountability at its
best
because she didn't hug and kiss me i
didn't listen to the warnings
and the red flags that she gave me so i
ran i bumped my head
now hold myself accountable thanks mom
that's just my topic on on victim
blaming i hope you guys understand that
i'm not trying to do that and if it
still comes across that way i'd love to
hear the feedback but
it's not what i'm trying to get at and
um yeah
that was pretty much all i had so let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below
[Music]
many
um like you know what i'll read it you
wouldn't blame a woman for staying
in uh a toxic relationship so why are
you blaming a guy
uh toxic partners are manipulative it's
how they
do bad things the cycle of
you know the word that we can't say busy
goes between moose affection
gaslighting put downs back to bush they
lose
and then they become affectionate loving
and caring to bring you back
in you know every time i say boost i
think of caboose
was the word
i'm sorry i'm trying to do this